okay for people who are joining this
livestream we actually haven't done
these one of these for awhile we are in
the process of wrapping up version 12
and don't have so many design meetings
right now because it's much they're just
fixing bugs but right now we have a
language completeness and consistency
meeting with a variety of topics so
let's get started
multiple argument form of width right so
you might remember we implemented the
VAR arc with so you later variables can
refer to earlier variable so how does it
work if I say with a equals B B equals C
B equals a plus two then you should get
so now I can say a squared or something
here
well B squared word and you'll see an a
inside of it yeah the curly braces
though for the first two arguments yeah
yeah okay and why do we do that why
don't we allow it without curly braces
because we need to disambiguate a think
what do we need to sunbaes yeah yeah it
broke things when we remove the need
because programmatically rewrite with it
becomes ambiguous right that was exactly
the problem was when when you when you
inject arguments into the width because
you're dynamically creating the first
argument of the width I think I think
there is code in the kernel and or front
end that does that and you ties rights
that when we removed the need for a list
than that code broke
um okay so the issue here is the issue
that we won you wanted to document it
once we completed the syntax coloring
but we haven't done it yet and we
haven't done it so we shouldn't document
it yet okay but the syntax column we
want involves correctly greening for
local variables here right even though
there's a stream of them correct okay
and by the way why does with not
complain I mean in this case here given
that we know that's wrong
or something like this we know that's
wrong why aren't we reddening that first
argument look in the new world where we
expect to have more code advisories that
is definitely something that we should
you know do as a code advisor I mean I I
don't think we have that I mean I just
don't think I don't think that front end
feature has ever been implemented no but
that's that look in general I have no
opposition to implementing it other than
John saying well okay so listen let's
let's put this in the inventory of
things that we want in the code advisory
system which will include many many
different complex syntactic things some
of which we think we are going to be
able to implement as a fairly
straightforward tree walking type thing
and some of which will require
sophisticated analysis of the code okay
and I think this is something earlier in
the next development cycle we need to be
looking at is this code advisory things
I think we have a model for how to do
code advisories using essentially speech
bubble type things near code that you
can X away if you don't like it you see
what I'm saying so it complains but then
if you if in fact it's okay just X out
the speech bubble and it won't it won't
ever complain about that again that
makes sense if you were so who can add
that to the user assistance should be
added to the user assistance meeting
okay I contend that yes
right so okay I will let just Roman
speak right so right now the as you can
see the third argument is is colored red
so in fact it's it's more than just not
having full coloring we're coloring
varargs with red and so Roman suggested
that maybe we could just not color that
red and possibly document it even if we
don't have no no we shouldn't do it it's
not necessary
by the way call on our livestream is
saying he's looking forward to this
forum with it does actually work right
now it's just that the syntax coloring
doesn't probably support it um yeah I
mean that the main problem is that email
address and quite heated and the basic
conclusion is that we don't document it
because syntax coloring doesn't work and
John says he doesn't implement syntax
coloring until it's document oh for
God's sake
and either complicated and I understand
that it's complicated but so I suggest
we could at least remove the word color
so we could document it and sometime in
the future
syntax coloring alright okay we can
remove the reddening that John said
would be easy I'm sure it is just a
verrell's thing yeah all right fine we
can do that that's what I'm suggesting
yes and we can do the documentation for
12:00 1:00 particularly if we can get I
mean particularly we can get some code
advisory thing and/or the actual syntax
coloring where is it obvious what the
syntax coloring should be because it's
essentially a localization of a
localization isn't it I mean should be
negative and and you can see what it
could be okay but oh so module does this
already yes no module does this right
module module says allows you to say Z
equals x
but that doesn't work around not thank
you that's the global X right if you not
power X inside of the module right the
problem right the difference is okay so
you saying go ahead is this gonna work
no and and it's not going to work and
there's no need for it because because
you can just do that inside the module
correct whereas with implements
read-only variables that's its purpose
in life yeah right so okay but so you're
saying that I could see what this should
do by just making that any type
optimistic
yeah I understand so I mean we have
Queen it's a bit ambiguous obviously
because we don't test two colors two
shades of green but at least I mean you
know which are scoped and actually it's
not that ambiguous because the right
hand side variables would never green
unless they were outer localized so to
speak yes exactly
so it's not that bad I mean we can
certainly it would certainly be happy
with something like that
yes quite happy yes that would be fine
okay all right look let's switch off the
reddening and let's see what's involved
in doing so test coloring for this okay
okay I mean John John would be here but
he had a family emergency as you may
know so okay
well that's that would be my suggestion
we're not gonna we're not gonna touch
this for 12 Oh otherwise yeah right John
right John says he can remove the
reddening for 12 though there's no way
to do the fun all right let's move on
what on earth is this okay so if you
directly call Wolfram or Wolf internal
well I guess Wolfram really this was
something that was added as part of the
licensing
right the Ottawa activation refresh we
had last summer and great come on not
found for me right because we non-mac we
don't put it on the path right so you
know so so Wolfram script
well well we'll give you something
different because that's that that's the
version of Wolfram script not the
version of the kernel ah it's not really
right I mean I've never seen that before
I have no I didn't even know that well
from script was at version 1.2 yeah I
mean if I say well from script here
uh-huh it's gonna come up Wolfram
language eleven point why isn't earth do
I have the eleven point three one here
well whatever it doesn't matter but but
um so that will be that will be what
that says so why does the - version
string come up with something completely
different with the versioning but I've
never even heard of because that is the
version of the Wolfram script binary
which can doesn't have to write it can
launch a local kernel it can go out to
the cloud it can launch different local
kernels I see so you're saying if I were
to do I see so if I say well from script
- cloud right you probably need to give
it like code or something yes okay okay
so that's more deep more complicated and
that's not giving me that this prompt
happens to give me a version number
right you're saying this is I I do not
like the fact that this doesn't have
dashes and is smooshed I mean this is
non smooshed
this has dashes and it's smooshed where
did that come from well this string
seems were like a rogue string to me
it's I mean that may just be that
Garrett Garrett are you Justin
no you're not actually watching a
colonel at this point right so great oh
it's the build issue with Wolfram script
that you need to have the proper well so
maybe Garrett should have got to taking
explains up where did that string
country so there was just a request to
that's the kind of builds platform for
Mack write down the actual system idea
right if you evaluate a dollar system ID
that's the value you would get right
that's where that string came from and
that was just kind of a request to have
version just so people could keep track
of all from scripts versions a little
bit better right because you only ever
have one wolfram script even if you have
20 very Mathematica as as like so I
wasn't really aware of this kind of
expanded Mac OS string and we could
change to using something like that
there does this even correct Mac space
OS space X it certainly was at a time
that was written okay fine changed its
conventions but but Tim okay so I mean
so what's the point here so the point is
look at this crazy output you get right
so we added well we added three things
for one was the - activate - just
activate the kernel and quit until and
they have an exit code that tells you
whether or not the activation was
successful right one was - machine ID
which just prints out the machine ID and
died in quits and then there was this -
version thing which just looks bizarre
and then is this weird amalgam of like
the version and license info and I think
that looks crazy right I mean there are
two directions we can go and one is a
more minimal direction like wolfram
script which is just have you know 12
and maybe the system what is documented
for I mean does Wolfram kernel have a
documented
um I mean we're rewriting it but this is
in fact is this option is documented
what you'll see in product is the old
page by the way that's just wrong what
it does but that's a documentation bug
somebody should report it all it has its
details you just open the detail I mean
that that's an incorrect page that's
right we're about good that if you look
at the next item it's the complete
rewrite of the page so we don't look
okay fine okay well so what's your point
the way you want to I mean this should
be flash license info or something yeah
so right well I did so my point is I
think we should decide what we want -
version well I guess we want to decide
if we want - version and if we do what
it should say or should we have a - I
think - version should do the same as it
does for well from Scripture should be a
a readable string that is the version
and wolfram script should change itself
to have the same string convention as
the startup banner okay guys I mean I
don't remember now but I doubt that that
was actually my suggestion that version
but we change but we certainly need a
command line option that outputs the
license ID just like it does it's a
machine ID and max license process this
would also be nice but well okay fine
but I was doing the lobby's a separate
separate one for that for the right it
won't it will take when like what five
minutes or two minutes to add a -
license ID option I have nope
if you wanted I should do it I think we
should do that I think that the
alternative here is to return some
structure but what's it going to be like
a JSON structure a Wolfram language
structure this is neither of those it's
some kind of pigeon JSON weird saying
yes I mean these these outputs should be
machine readable so their machine ID is
perfect you see every script language
can easily
laughter but the even the dollar license
ID : it's not necessary if you have so
let's have separate also directed
infinitive an i would rather much oughta
like to see infinity yeah I agree
that's crazy what we have that would you
like to see infinity oh just the string
and vinegar yes right separate names for
these for these outputs right I mean
this is very early I mean this may just
be an artifact of the fact that we're
printing it so early in the cycle that
no output form isn't active yet
right and so right but we can just have
a special case for that because we know
this is an integer infinity right why a
single dash for long options this is
because that is our our long time
convention there is a there there is a
more modern convention that uses a
single dash for single character options
and a and two dashes for options that
are whole words which I believe is a
good new convention we make really
perfect but we I mean there are plenty
of well I'm there are plenty of POSIX
programs that use single dashes for
everything should we support both um so
any ambiguity in that it's not a
standard thing to do yeah well fine all
right
okay turning them into green pages
examples are not quite finished okay so
these are in I can yeah and they were
last touched on Wednesday so I presume
you don't your documentation I don't
think I do
Wednesday it's now Friday no I do not
um okay well how do I get to them so
there's a program pages it's about a
third of the way down and then if you
click on the O it will give you a little
chooser or you can I
yeah so we have a Wolfram you and the
Wolfram colonel me okay how much detail
are we going over these in as much as
you want
I mean basically I wanted you to see the
main in the description and why does
this even exist
this Wolfram thing as opposed to well
from script because that is the kernel
executable but this is the kernel
executable isn't it not on all platforms
maybe you should read the descriptions
and then you'll understand device
typically keyboard
what is this gonna look like for the web
engine what is this gonna look like okay
who here knows what the whole wolfram
engine is our note here um does uh node
know what the
I know this our note here or not okay so
I mean somebody who knows what we're
doing with wool from engine versus
wolfram I mean where's the engine Steven
please read the description I've read
them I just read this I just read it
okay there I didn't get any response no
I was I was silently reading hello well
at least I read the left-hand one or the
same program okay console-based Colonel
session normally reads input from
standardin from device did you mean
device or a device from a device that's
a typo yes okay um
right so the point is on Mac and Linux
Wolfram and Wolfram kernel are the same
program and you know basically one is a
symbolic link to the other okay on
Windows they are two different programs
because one works in the command dot exe
console that's Wolfram and Wolfram
kernel is the thing that launches is the
Windows mode program which launches a
little you know window console thing
that you type into if you remember back
from your Windows days okay so I mean
they're very they're very similar and we
can probably make them even a bit more
similar but they are distinct programs
and for example on Windows Wolfram
kernel can't read standard input or
standard output be you you can't
redirect input or output because it's
disconnected from the shell because it's
a window Windows has the strict
separation between console mode programs
and windows mode programs so once you
launch it off okay let's zoom out for a
second here okay so we have this notion
of wolfram engine we are about to start
distributing wolf Mangin as a separate
thing what is the binary that is being
distributed in the wolf management
package well
zoom it would be wealth from / Wolfram
colonel okay but the the binary that we
are documenting people using is well
from script well okay but we don't
really want but we're little we're we're
the Wolfram engine this is very
confusing and probably wrong okay
because remember there's also things
like Wolfram web engine which is
something I mean what you've written
about Wolfram kernel is that it's
accessible from a device or W STP
connection okay yes until for example
boy from is the program that is invoked
when you launch the parallel camera so
it is a fairly important diner but
that's just assembling kernels so it
doesn't matter okay look look I mean the
question is what is that background
noise by the way could you okay um oh
boy okay
how do these options relate to the
Wolfram
Crypt options they're completely
separate but all they do they correspond
I mean are they are they compatible with
so any options that Wolfram script
doesn't I don't know about it passes to
the colonel it starts okay this doesn't
look like a green page I mean these ones
well look at this if you looked at the
source page of Wolfram script you would
see it look okay fine so this is gonna
turn into a green page yes okay all
right so what you're telling me is that
these up here - script what the hell is
that - script file is the government of
- file - wolf em script it's sort of
equivalent yes it's what's - PW file
does Wolfram script have one of those
that that's four that's PW file this
password file if you might know non Stan
like if Wolfram script is calling a
kernel then it will pass all of the
criminal options to it and the kernel
will interpret them
but I understand that I'm asking I'm
asking in wolfram script any capability
okay so we've not documented a -
password or - PW file have we all have
we direct button or from script yes we
have - password right there that's a
separate option that one's meant for the
cloud authentication rather than the
password file but but this says -
password it's the same named option by
the way also that this font is wrong
here there's a bunch of things that are
glitched up and in here those vertical
bars could do with being gray and the
bunch of silly stuff here somebody from
documentation should look at I think one
thing to understand is that the boy from
I know he goes back - it says new in
version 1 so you shouldn't expect too
much consistency between those option
names and the ones fine but I think what
we should be doing is okay look here's
what I think I think we should get rid
of you know we have Wolfram script
whatever binary orphan script is calling
for the Wolfram engine which we need to
make that binary be I mean why is that
binary directly callable why is it not
why don't we ask everybody
you might just call it directly I mean
why shouldn't I guess my question to you
is why shouldn't you do call it directly
I mean maybe okay fair enough fair
enough okay but if we call it directly I
don't think this confusion with Wolfram
kernel versus Wolfram is crazy that's
crazy because you're never going to know
which is which
so which one on under windows Wolfram is
one which launches a window or not well
now
it's the one that launches a kernel into
a console interface like it says right
there so that's the one which doesn't
open the window whereas the one called
Wolfram kernel does open a window
yes oh my god I would never have guessed
that never never but typically that one
that launches as a Windows application
would have an icon which you click but
the the wall command line program will
not usually not be invoked by a icon so
that current that confusion does it
decreased in practice well okay I'm
sorry but but the thing that has an icon
okay look let's make a list here of what
we actually have I mean this is kind of
a nutso list okay what we've got we've
got Wolfram script what it's gone wrong
with my something is very very very
wrong with my stylesheet settings and
that needs to be debugged actually um
it's a search my here yes I'm here can
you show me which one you're using okay
okay
in any case okay so first first thing is
well from script okay so what is that
roughly that is a a scripting wrapper um
that can call the Wolfram engine no but
we're calling it a Wolfram engine that's
the branding of the thing okay maybe
you've completely changed it again but
isn't the Wolfram engine everything it
is yes right so that's different from
butBut no but the front end note no the
wolf mention is ax
through the colonel but it contains a
front end for purposes of rasterization
and so on okay that could call the wolf
mansion locally on a server in the cloud
etc right um where am i saving this
Sushma
where should I save this should I say
this in product notes or should I say
designs extra blue notes miscellaneous
that's a wimp out because yeah and I
don't know anyway I asked you to save
this okay
well I'll save this under under um well
don't we have a command line don't we
have a thing for command line programs
there might be something so well from
script but I need to check it wrong no
there isn't
okay let me just write this is command
line programs okay so it's under
brilliantly it's under miscellaneous
which is always a wimp out okay
scripting wrapper that can call well
okay let's write our definitions down
okay well from engine could somebody see
if our node is available both our node
and Todd gala will be relevant to this
okay um okay
wolfram engine well let's start off with
Wolfram kernel okay I would say that is
the raw binary that implements kernel
functionality it does not include the
front end which is a separate binary
okay you're missing a nut from that
sentence right thank you
um okay well from engine is the program
that
can be called through now let's see how
does it get called through or from
script WS TP etc to get Wolfram language
functionality it the Wolfram engine
bundle includes the front end for
rasterization well yeah I would disagree
with the word program there I mean it's
an application or application bundle
which this thing here yes okay well does
every platform call it an application at
this level okay let's just write down
the other things that we know
okay Wolfram web engine that's the thing
that can be called that's this can be
connected
that's connectable to a web server okay
and probably nobody in this meeting
knows about that that's war from web
engine for I don't even remember what
the name of the thing is um a to EE or
something what is it called a - I don't
remember what it's called switch when do
you remember what that's called oh can
you look it up yep um okay so then we
have much more sophisticated levels of
things like wolf an application server
um that is callable through HTTP okay
it's different from these things because
these are not a wolfram engine a naked
wolf Mangin can't be accessed through
HTTP it doesn't provide it doesn't
expose an HTTP interface right it's not
acting like a web server makes sense
you
todd todd join here
in Japan too what's like this idea so in
the process of being connected of
connecting okay so these things here are
all uh okay so okay so
wolfram engine is an application bundle
correct which is called by war from
script Wolfram web engine is also an
application bundle that is called by
Wolfram application server correct Todd
can you confirm it I'm not not sure well
first of all I thought I wouldn't say
that wasn't script cause well from
engine isn't it wasn't good part of
automation I thought you were saying
earlier today that Wolfram Anjan was the
name for the you know a suite of things
including the player front-end
no no no no no no the plan front-end is
completely separate that's completely
separate that's that's just happens to
be included in the that's just because
of the distribution binaries no that's a
conveyor okay so no joining us also it
doesn't really matter about that but
well it does matter because another
confusion I mean that's a completely
separate thing okay well there has been
some debate as to what the name ball
from web engine refers to whether that
refers to essentially the Java the thing
that we used to call web Mathematica or
whether we've been through this about 18
times okay we've been through find it
I'm trying to figure out how okay what
was the latest version at the Wolfram
application server called the cause of
war from web engine I'm trying to say
what that could be if that fenders were
were true okay so what I'm understanding
is that this web engine has support what
is the name of that glue code I do I
have to go look it up I go look it up
look it up I can tell you what are you
asking what could what Google are you
referring to
I'm asking what is this the Wolfen web
engine is for a particular style of
connector to web servers what is that
style of connector I do know what I'm
talking about
well from web engine is a are you
talking about like a servlet container
what you're talking about that sort of
like over here what we're naming this is
wool from web engine library for um a
i/o HTTP j2ee etc right so this is this
is a wrapper library look that's a rotor
library then okay so this is for Python
Java etc right so that's the thing that
calls Wolfram engine right this is
another thing that is another wrapper
that calls Wolfram engine that makes
sense yes so I mean both from web engine
library for j2ee is the thing that we
used to call what method no it isn't
it's not the sense that is a that is
that would have been a good name for oh
no okay fine whatever but the
application server is a containerized
thing that can be stood up to deliver
api etc etc etc right right okay so that
is a complete deliverable thing this is
purely a library where you get to stand
up your own web server okay that
includes a web server makes sense this
does not include a web server does not
include a web server right you're on
your own in terms of having a web server
right can somebody give me the link to
the the client library for Python page
yeah did okay just send me that link
please okay so these things as I
understand it the client library that
these are alternatives okay so Wolfram
script can be thought of or put it up
with these okay Wolfram script is aka
Wolfram language client library for the
shell right that's what it essentially
is right correct
so that right or not if description I
think
you
you
what the hell is this i know'd whatever
you sent me is not right
all I got was this I got a page with no
formatting and a very giant yeah that's
that's that's the same issue debt is
been going on with the functional
repository in a neural network
repository if you refresh the page it
will be fine but it's I already did that
twice but put just put a slash at the
end of the URL oh sorry that's okay so
that is it it's copied it I did copy it
so yeah okay okay but listen obviously
we got to make it work without the slash
then um yeah yeah this is just a
Dorian's you know it own version so okay
all right fine so just to be clear what
this does this calls Wolfram engine
correct from from Python yes so
somewhere in here there is a thing that
says let's see oh for God's sake could
you tell him set up is two words but it
is a verb like that okay I do declare
not look at this page yet just dis dis
version I don't think it's been pushed
life yet this is just okay so so if we
look here there will be a place where it
says start a Wolfram engine if I'm not
mistaken where is that language session
right that starts the session and the
binary that the the binary that it calls
is Wolfram kernel are you serious yes
because that's how you access kernel
functionality and the kernel can call
the front end if it needs it which is
why I say that the Wolfram engine is an
application bundle which includes the
kernel so concludes Mathematica or
Wolfram desktop or whatever the name of
the front end is it includes wolfen
kernel no it doesn't it doesn't include
that
you can't start the front end
independently from wolf Mangin in other
words you know if you take something
like wool from wand if if I have
Mathematica or Wolfram desktop installed
I double you know when you double-click
on on that application they're called
Mathematica or it calls Wolfram desktop
and that is the program that started I
know but that's not what it happens in
the Wolfman engine case
the wolf magic case is not doing that
right it's not doing that it doesn't
have those binaries it has a front end
which is using which it uses for
rasterization you can't get a notebook
interface this has no notebook interface
even if it has no notebook interface it
must still have the front end binary for
the kernel to call it it does but it has
no built-in interface so don't tell me
that it has a Wolfram one you know
system application because it doesn't it
doesn't it has I don't know what the
front end is called I don't know the
front end binary is cool but it's not
called one of those things I didn't say
it was called one of those skin does
anybody know what it is called probably
Wolfram engine the front end not a
chance
what is it called I have to check on my
oh it's called Mathematica you need for
the product Mathematica but it but
that's not what it's called and Wolfram
engine is it I'm pretty sure it's called
but that's stupid and completely wrong
if that's the case yeah yeah that would
be wrong it let me check Oh second okay
so it has a component COBOL from kernel
you say it's currently called wool from
engine but that's wrong it's wrong
that's wrong wrong I know I know there's
lots of books this is this is not a
released product it's not even like
properly configured yet so so what
should we call it we call it front end
should we call it notebook interface I'm
the PI we I believe we called that
Wolfram front end right so we could call
it well from front end okay I mean
that's certainly
you know it should be the notebook front
end because there might be a different
front end it's very big mouthful what do
you think I mean that's at least clear
nobody's confused about what it is I
ever done my screen all the names right
now if you want to go over the full list
so we don't miss anything can you send
it to me yeah I don't use email in this
case cuz it's gonna have fun right and
my claim is that I mean I guess I don't
know for this effect for effect because
it's not a finished program program but
product but my claim is that the Wolfram
engine will have both Wolfram kernel and
Wolfram in it on Windows those will be
separate programs okay okay so we're
gonna come to that in just a second okay
so Wolfram engine has so Wolfman gen
bundle I guess as a courtesy did you get
email as a courtesy the bundle the
Wolfram engine bundle will include
Wolfram script language client library
for Python etc right but the actual
thing that is called the engine mean
these will be separately downloadable
the actual thing called the engine is
that bundle yep see if you can pull up
your I mean these are the names we have
to discuss if that's the purpose of this
discussion so there's the the product
name we're able from research and easy
Wolfram engine 12 oh so that's the
product name Wolfram engine but where
are you looking here we're just
directory at the very top above the
table
this directory that's a directory you're
and that's the installation directory
top-level right
so normally we'll say something like
instead of Wolfram mention we'll say
something like Wolfram desktop or it
will say Mathematica right right
named in an aversion that's the standard
yes organizations that we've had for you
know like 20 30 years right I've been
here so yeah I remember I redid it it
was a total mess like four or five years
in so yes this is so Dan Adams
configuration system files are all
directories that the dot files are you
know usually not visible or detected
just gonna you know you're like licensed
our text is the above-mentioned license
that Eric shocked you know has provided
yep
then math dot exe and Wolfram that exe
are not the same things those are crazy
they should be math dot exe should be
removed okay
are we are we taking notes in this
meeting or do I need to know I'm taking
notes okay thank you
math kernal should be removed math
kernel and wolfram kernel are ours also
the same sort of can I guess that's
stupid but that's that's just because
they started with math with a
mathematical lay out and started
renaming and removing things yeah yeah
yeah can be removed but you know like it
so Wolfram and Cheney XE that's gonna
start that's basically the front end
binary okay so that will be Wolfram
notebook front end will fine
notebook friends okay is there any
problem with it with the name of that
length I don't care what it's called
nobody ever sees it say is it ever gonna
be visible but if you do directory no I
but it if there's some crazy Windows
program launcher that is an 8.3 you know
something or other
no it's not really a front-end right I
mean you don't double click on it that
it's just a service thing for the kernel
well it opens that's all it it opens as
a player it opens like the player you
can still watch you know open notebooks
with it's just like a player in a
read-only mode okay so if it's like well
yes it is serving the role of yeah but
not an editable for you know note that
is it's a maybe it should be called
different something different rather
than the open can just call it the
wolfram player because that's the
functionality provides
that's super confusing okay well unless
unless you want it to be an identical
binary - what happens if you download
just the player bundle it's pretty much
the same thing okay but what is it
exactly the same thing it is the same
binary it's only the license that's
different I think are you sure in which
case what is it called in the notebook
player layout what is that what is the
notebook player layout called what is
the analog of okay all of these things
take a second in the player it's cold
well from player dot exe right now if we
want this to be the thing that launches
the GUI so you can open notebooks I
don't understand why we don't want this
call wolfram engine right I mean wha
right well want the title bar to say
well from engine right so I'll send you
two player file no it shouldn't the
title bar should say wolf and player if
it's opening an actual notebook
so that that's the list of files you get
in the player at the moment but the
house wolf inscript original oh that's
that's my I was just thinking okay all
right fine okay so the issue is it so
happens that the notebook service
program in wolfram engine is the same as
well from player at the present time
right great might not always be that way
the matter of fact it's it's installed
the same build so it's like even like
the same number of bytes if you look at
that okay whatever whatever whatever as
it happens right now it might not always
be that way right so that's a core
layouts where it where things are pulled
from so it's you know it'll little well
we're gonna make an effort to make them
the exact same thing well I don't think
we should commit to that because I think
I think the correct name for this binary
is wool from player for the wool from
player binary look so this is I mean the
name can be different but the yeah I
understand for for QA purposes it's nice
to have this exact same binaries okay
that's the binary but it the wool from
player also has a wool from kernel in it
because it needs it as a service so it's
two different ways round in the case of
the wool from engine the kernel needs
something like the player as a service
in the case of the player
it needs the kernel as a service yep
right okay so the question is and I'm
pretty sure that only exists right okay
that that's not relevant right yet okay
okay
Wolfram only exists non player type
distributions because it by definition
launches a sort of yeah I understand
which is a rewrite kernel yeah okay so
so in this case here
this thing officially could be called
you know this is essentially something
like a Wolfram notebook service is that
true but that's gonna be so freaking
confusing yeah I mean we do have Wolfram
notebook interface but it isn't because
it isn't providing the interface it's
not providing the readwrite interface
it's only providing a service
wolfram notebook reader or from the book
player well then we might as well call
it player that's what it is it plays
notebooks all right okay fine
so then the the provisional decision is
inside the wolf management application
bundle there is Wolfram kernel and
Wolfram player inside the or from player
bundle there's also or from player which
is now in charge and Wolfram kernel
which is subsidiary ok any tire grease
with that sure ok ok ok so now okay so
that's the notebook service provides a
notebook service subsidiary to the
kernel ok now next question
the so all of these things this Wolfram
language client library calls Wolfram
end Wolfram kernel was that correct
correct yes which can be part of which
is part of the Wolfram engine
application bundle yep
ok is it in a position to call directly
into the Wolfram kernel that exists in
the Wolfram player application bundle
probably not
it I think it does I mean we have we I I
well I don't know if it's using we have
we have code that allows it to find
allows things to find Paranal well I
mean write the same code that Wolfers
script does uses to find that the kernel
binary if you haven't manually specified
one is a library that could be linked
into the Java I don't know that it is ok
so that tribute it or not the player
card the player on Deauville deny a
connection based on licensing ok fine
which is probably the correct thing to
do thing except there's a bug in 11 3 by
which you can do it through or from
script I believe ok but but cannot call
off and colonel in the Wolfson player
application bundle there's one other
case we shouldn't forget and that's the
kernel that is used in parallel
computing and so when I SSH into remote
machine I have to know that there is a
binary which at the moment is called Roy
from that is on the search path and that
is log that launches the color and
that's at least on Linux and probably
Mac OS so they said put probably a user
local bean boy from or you Supino's one
and that is something we need so that
this works without having to know where
exactly that thing is
okay so wilmut okay so hold on a second
there's a separate issue which is a we
already it's called both and player not
wolf notebook player is that correct
sorry this thing here is that's correct
name I believe it's called wolf in
player ok last I knew was possible from
player ok ok so the next is a path
discoverable wolfram or similar
path discoverable wolfram binary right
that's what you're asking for oh yeah
eg used in peril computing possibly in
remote kernels yes and ultimately also
the front end when it can connect to a
kernel well that's well I mean also also
front end calling mm-hmm calling remote
kernels okay so this is something where
basically the use case that we would
expect is a pure you know thing where
you go you know you're purely going
basically you know ssh machine and then
you're saying something like that from
my little USDP yeah okay so what that
did okay so that that did the right
thing for me is sh tin to a random linux
machine then DRAM that's what i rely on
okay there's also which is assembly
they're both siblings to the same
program so because on linux there's no
difference between wolf removal from
kernel I mean on Windows it would
probably be better to use well from
kernel because you can look at so you're
saying that if I do that I'll get the
same thing yep okay okay
oh I bizarrely got something that said
Mathematica kernel that just means the
last wolfram product you installed was a
Mathematica another Wolfram desktop so
when it because I see because that what
that's doing is its rewriting the path
program okay so the question here is
what is the path is the quotes path
program right how is it affected by well
from one installation or mathematical
installation or all kinds of other
random installations etc right I mean in
the future the thing you would install
on a machine to be used for parent
computing would be the boy from ng
because that contains the kernel and the
service content so that's the one that
should be on the path if there are
several animation okay fine
okay so let's walk through this okay so
what we're saying here is that right now
we have not defined what
right now we have wolfram script which
does whatever it does it's it's
effectively the shell I mean well from
script seems to me to be the thing that
I would expect you know if you're
starting a shell which SSH does by its
very name right if you're starting a
shell then what you should be using is
the client library program for the shell
aka Wolfram script and I think that
works if you try to adjust it well it
may work but I mean we have to decide
what we want to standardize on here so
so hold on so you're saying if I say SSH
Wolfram script you're saying I will get
yet another copy of the exact same
things up now it has the correct yes
engine thing so you are correct I mean
that's the one you would expect to call
for interactive use no but but I will
not use working script I will use boy
from /ws VP for parallel computing okay
so hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on so this is so a path
discoverable binary I think the correct
answer here okay well from script
doesn't have a WS DP option is that
correct okay so to me okay so I'm gonna
make a claim about how this should work
okay
claim is the the pure shell interaction
ie stood in stood out etc right hmm is
Wolfram script okay
then I'm going to claim the WS TP
interaction endpoint basically is
Wolfram kernel well that's not
completely true well what is true
I think Wolfram script calls the Wolfram
kernel is all right
sure does this is providing script calls
Wolfram well okay but I want to get rid
of this thing called Wolfram okay
because I think it's confusing and we'll
come to the windows case in a minute no
we can't get rid of it because everybody
depends on it's like peephole
I mean it's all hard-coded into it would
be just like yeah okay okay fine well we
can we can symbolic link it to something
else let's define what we want to have
happen the pure shell interaction will
transcript do we agree the thing that is
intended to be interactive with through
the shell is well from script me I mean
I use both of these for different
purposes it's just both of which both
Wolfram and and actually will from
kernel when I'm on Windows okay hold on
okay okay so Wolfram you're using
because it has a WS TP endpoint is that
correct no I'm using it because I want
to just ok fine but that that's just
that's just because you've been doing
that for 25 years or something I mean
isn't it the case that will from script
you know if you are a system that has
multiple kernels on it multiple installs
that wolfram script is going to pick one
of them that is correct which is
probably the other reason that I use
Wolfram script differently from you know
a standalone kernel sometimes is how
much control I want over which thing is
actually running
sure right but I'm saying if you want a
generic discoverable shell interaction
use Wolfram script yes if you want a
generic discoverable launcher binary
using you know some system call for
example right as opposed to using the
shell if you would launching through a
system call you should launch a binary
like Wolfram colonel I claim do you
agree yes okay and the reason you need
Wolfram is that what there is only ever
one Wolfram script but there there are
many Wolfram's okay fine well let's
understand that okay eg launched through
a system call right as opposed to okay
so the typical thing you'll be doing
there is to say Wolfram kernel - W STP
is that correct to get a WS t to have it
exposed at OSTP endpoint yes together
with ten other options which tell it by
the police in order to connect and so on
okay fine for me the only thing is the
important thing is that it is on the
path and it doesn't change too
frequently right at the moment Wolfram
is the one that is in the default
okay so now somebody was explaining that
you're saying okay so pure shell
interaction is this and on any given
system there would only be one copy of
all from script you claim no there's
yeah
okay so now well from Colonel what what
what is this thing okay so what's the
role of the Wolfram program in all of
this stuff it is product at least on
Linux and it's on it's the thing that
from script calls to actually launch and
a rebel on Windows Bing the script calls
to launch a rebel because it doesn't
call so wolfram colonel
because welcome colonel is a Windows
Mode program or the console mode program
but why doesn't I mean in in the style
of wolf and Colonel having a WS TP
option why doesn't it have options
you know WS TP is not a rebel right WS
TP is a you know as a protocol endpoint
what's your point my point is that I
think it should have from what you are
describing what I would expect to see is
you know all from - console mode well
from the kernel - console possible -
whatever the other one is called what is
the other one anyway that's just not how
Windows works explain Windows has a
strict separation between console mode
programs and and Windows fine okay okay
fine so but-but-but
so you're saying that the binary has to
be different the wrapper binary has to
be different under Windows yes okay so I
would claim which one you know that
Windows kernel is also a rebel binary I
know it's a rebel right now I'm claiming
that that actually is sort of a an abuse
that it's a rebel binary okay so let me
understand in the Windows what is the
analog of what I'm doing here on a Mac
or on a Linux machine there is what's
that there isn't so this type of thing
there is no analyst so what are the two
types of programs on Windows yeah lemme
sure okay
go ahead so alright my Windows machine
went to sleep so bright but ah like I
said on Linux Wolfram and Wolfram kernel
are both sim links to the same program
right there's there's only one guy I
know I understand them I do understood
that so you're gonna show on Windows how
it works differently yes wonder where
that is um ok buddy
all right so right so if I do well from
kernel it launches a a window rebel ok
which apparently I have some
environments that variable set whereas
if I do I just do Wolfram Daddy eggsy
then it opens in the shell I understand
I got it
ok I get it I get it I get it ok very
very weird ok can you and share ok so I
would claim that what really should
exist there is something called you know
ok so the windows case basically we're
talking about here I'm claiming what
should exist is that one thing the pure
apple is just like Wolfram script is is
is like a a you know is like the DOS you
know quotes dos rebel that was what you
showed me second right is what I would
call the door Apple what ok then I would
claim there should be another binary
called something like I don't know
console or something which is the you
know windowed rebel
that's what I would climb on windows
that there are two different things and
that neither of those is Wolfram kernel
which is the thing which maybe as a
courtesy will launch as a rebel
sometimes but that's not really its
point it's real point is to be a thing
that is a binary that could be called by
a system call that can expose various
end points like WS TP and that's how it
works and that under windows in addition
to Wolfram script which would do the
same thing as it does on every other
platform one would have a thing called
orphan console now the discoverable
thing on the path is yet a different
thing because presumably what you want
to be discoverable on the path for
Windows is the DOS rebel program is that
true or it doesn't really it's neither
it's a thing which is gonna have a WS TP
option it's going to be the thing that
can be called by a system call is that
right okay so let's go through this
again so I claim Wolfram kernel the fact
that it does something by default when
you launch it on a shell command line is
purely coincidental that's some kind of
historical courtesy right because I
claim that otherwise I mean most
programs you know don't expose a rental
by default they just you know most
random you know you start a random C
program it does not expose a repple by
default this one happens to do that just
as a courtesy
but normally expects to get you know WS
T P messages and so on make sense
you know now but go ahead but the
Wolfram script das repple is provided by
the write the Wolfram dot exe binary I
mean there's nothing in Wolfram script
that takes care of the repple I mean
it's just it just launches to you okay
that's fine
who cares I mean that's my point is what
is the user exposed version of this what
it does in the inside I mean you know
the full layout has ten thousand files
in it right which one that happens to
call is its own separate issue unless
what Sam so what I'm claiming is for
that okay so let's look at what calls
what so if you're if you're going
through okay so for things like this the
client library for Python this calls
Wolfram kernel because it's calling it
with a W STP option is it not the client
library uses W STP is that correct todd
todd it makes Garrett
think it's through J link which I please
okay so what could you answer the
question then please
I am I correct in believing that the
client library uses Python users okay no
it does not use W STP but WJ link zero
one you need yes limit Python library is
0 mq + J link uses double your TV okay
so let me just write that down because
ok so python library uses ZM q
a library uses j-link
which uses WS TP so is it the case that
there's a way of starting wool from
kernel exposes as the MQ end point
nothing built in well how do you how do
you eat how do you get to it through 0
mq not exactly sure he probably maybe
send some man line you know - run
something or other that makes it wait on
Jeremy's rocket ok let's go through this
again ok that okay we've got a program
that is trying to interface with this
Wolfram kernel thing right it can send
it the protocol and packets and so on of
WS TP right it can send it the protocol
and packets of zmq well it can also just
call it yes you know one argument
execute someone Wolfram language code on
startup and then connect to that zmq and
ok fine all right foot so so it could it
might or might not be packaged in a
single command line argument for Wolfram
kernel but right the end if the end
effect of this is that Wolfram kernel
will either communicate through what is
all this stuff I'm just trying to look
at the code that explains what it's
using ok all right ok ok fine all right
so again let's come back to this again
please ok so I think what we want I
claim a quotes I claim the correct
answer here is a shell path the shell
path discoverable binary ok the shell
discoverable binary should be war from
script fine now that she'll path
discoverable binary doesn't want to be
cool but the W STP option does it exam
but can Wolfram script be called with
the W STP option yes
image it just passes it to the kernel
that it calls right if it doesn't get
any options that it specifically
understands it just exacts a kernel okay
fine okay but that's an extra step so if
someone wants connected to a WS TP kind
of Wolfram kernel directly they may not
want to rely on Wolfram to script to
just pick an installation they may want
kind of a specific ace I guess what I'm
saying is whatever is the last program
you install look the problem is this
concept of a blind thing that a shell
path discoverable is very weird I mean I
know everybody does it but it's very
weird and dangerous and Roman what is
the in the kernel connection manager
world do you still expect to have the
shell path discoverable binary well I
mean it's the default in all the scripts
that are launched for making a
connection and you can change that of
course if you for example want to call a
specific version you would you would
make a change but because Tyler tools
master and sub currents can be different
versions and there is a lot of
compatibility I would really
like to just have by default a ball game
called boy from a wooden kernel that
understands WS DP and doesn't go through
another for Calexico anything and just
works as he case in the last 20 years
all right so let me make a suggestion
then okay
well you're you're saying okay show path
discoverable binary you say should have
both well from script and wolfram kernel
yeah and that Wolfram kernel is
primarily used in the - w STP mode maybe
in the future there'll be a native wmq
mode is that right yeah whatever I mean
it's the thing that for example the
front end we launched when it launches a
color that our tools will launch when it
launches the chroma and probably also
the under and the world from cloud when
the cloud system launches a kernel
that's the thing ecology and also a
console so just to be clear then this
kernel said so for example the thing to
say about Wilton colonel so welcome
kernel is is a pure non i conned binary
is that right yes I mean by the father
creates an eye if you launch it
interactively then by the father does
well from script have an icon well no
because it runs and
right if you launch Wolfram script from
the Windows Explorer then it will open a
das window
okay so again has no binary is again non
I conned right yeah okay fair enough so
then I claim that the the third thing we
want under under Windows is Wolfram
console which launches a console with a
Wolfram language repple right okay so
the only thing we is now missing is what
happens to the thing that the binary
that is currently called Wolfram okay
yes people agree I think we should but
is I think it's the only way clear way
to do this what is that right now what
is that called right now it's all
internal oh for God's sake that's what I
showed you but you just said that it
doesn't generate an icon it can be set
to not generate an icon how with
command-line option there's no icon yes
this is a total mess not power mess it's
the mess of the inventors of this
operating system I know
I mean if we transition away from the
world from binary we have to do that
very carefully because well we can we
can alias the wool from binary to
something I just don't know what the
heck it's alias - what would it be Elias
- would be a less to Wolfram script or
did something else well I mean it should
support the current use case of being
caused by WS DP and so on so it should
be the voice of Colonel I mean non
Windows platforms Wolfram disassembling
to go from kernel it already is
assembling the Wolfram girl and exists
there just for compatibility okay it's
just you know on Windows they're
actually separate things and and I think
you know I think it's a corner case that
you know I think just you know writing
the documentation is the amount of
effort that's just I mean I bother and
I've already done 90% of that first step
of writing the documentation they should
remove great graphical interface from
Wolfram kernel on Windows because it's
its way absolute and then we can
normalize these things to me which might
assume I try your response to that I
don't buy my initial reaction is not to
agree with that
look I think the main issue here I don't
think there's anything wrong with having
look listen you know we thought we'd
seen the last of command-line dust-like
interfaces but then there's some random
you know then we had like early
raspberry PI's and things which were
admits
Linux but you know we thought we'd seen
the last of 1988 style interfaces but we
haven't so I don't think we should kill
off a Windows console because I think we
haven't seen the last of them for some
reason some crazy thing you know some
some spacecraft on its way to wherever
it'll turn out the only thing it has is
a Windows console with it can bring up
um however the name is wrong the fact
that wolfram kernel is the thing that
brings up that console is wrong now
whether we you know are there any
programs that will automatically be
calling wool from kernel I doubt it well
no no no I meant I meant for the purpose
of bringing up a Windows console Oh No
right so so that means we don't break
anything by having I mean look I mean if
you want to make it will require changes
because right now it's in the start well
then we should call it Wolfram console
because that's what it is oh I would
think I mean that case seems very
obscure anyway oh gosh what a mess
okay so so that still leaves the
question of the binary called Wolfram
what does it do because you claim we
need to have it because that's what
things have been expecting to call
forever and that's I don't care what
implements it it could be any
complicated name because it's somewhere
in the 10,000 files that we ship right
but the thing that matters is what the
users call it
right and the thing that weeks want the
users to use is Wolfram script that's
the thing that has all the features etc
etc etc I think that's the thing if
you're using the shell you call Wolfram
script now if you're using an exec
inside of some system call you shouldn't
be using Wolfram script because Wolfram
script is a creature of the shell well
you know in the bath it depends what you
want to do I would argue that whether
you want to use why-why-why what is
Wolfram in this case it's a symlink to
or from Connell isn't it so you should
just use Wolfram colonel in that case
well that is the raw binary that is the
thing that you can call as a system call
well I don't want to delve into all the
details but I mean that's a gross
oversimplification because the binary
you have on Lennox you also have the
shell script that launches it because
you need to modify LD library path it's
okay all right okay well I okay fine
okay the binary COBOL from what do we
want it to do if we have such a binary
and you claim we need such a binary so I
would claim that that binary mmm oh my
gosh what the heck should it do well
it's the thing that no that's all from
script that's what should launch a
ripple in a DOS window if or if
something else does it as well so be it
but Wolfram script is the canonical way
of launching a ripple in a generic shell
or DOS window
Garrett sorry if we want it as a legacy
thing so that people can point at it we
probably wanted to
have the same behavior which is have WS
TP available do the same kind of
behavior is all from Colonel you and
then it becomes a deprecated thing on
what we document for people who want to
use the shell is Wolfram script as I
keep on saying I have no objection to
that I just think we should properly
just like we have you know proper
documentation for Wolfram script and we
have proper documentation for
Mathematica that exe and so then we need
proper documentation for Wolfram kernel
right and and Wolfram Colonel whatever
these are they've got to be sensibly
consistent with the Wolfram script stuff
it these are implemented and very kind
of old and used in a lot of things is
the compatibility with this but the
things going forward that we can
document can be sensible and consistent
and not just different like - run I mean
that's the equivalent I suppose no -
code no it's not what's different about
it it's that it is to run initialization
code prior to the launch of the can we
have an init thing for that here do we
have that what do we not have that here
I don't think we have okay so look look
the finger has to happen and let's make
this separate from this meeting is to
look at the options too often kernel and
the how they correspond to Wolfram
script okay I think we've kind of
concluded here that the Wolfram binary
as such will be supported merely as a
legacy thing that it will try to support
as many of the options of of these other
thing I mean maybe we have to still
support math as a legacy thing in
certain installation okay we need to get
off this topic
go ahead
[Music]
so we know because we also need for
automatic activation or at least we
can't have you can't okay alright okay
so there's yet more hair here yes oh my
gosh the hard part is that it's so many
stuff so many things are grandfathered
in you know like I know but I think the
approach we should take is the following
okay
we document a nice clean you know
logical set of things going forward we
can also have as footnote legacy
documentation other things that we leave
hanging around for purposes of legacy
programs fair but the thing we need to
concentrate on is what is the
documentation going forward yeah now
we've had we've had a few questions on
the live stream which um let's see if
well from script is sensitive develop
path how does dollar LD underscore
library path deal with that a comments
at I what was the question
if wolfram script is sensible to
sensitive to dollar path
how does dollar LD underscore library
path how about dollar LD underscore
library part doesn't well so Garrett you
would it doesn't it doesn't called does
it called the kernel directly or does it
call the wolfram shell script that
wrapper it calls the wrapper because I
represent the kind of environment
variables it needs in some cases right
so basically LD library path will be
modified to suit okay okay look okay so
bottom line here we are stuck with a lot
of legacy stuff but we want a document
going forward clean new
consistent stuff so let's figure out
what that should be okay let's just take
one minute we should do the allowed so
then we should jump to the last item
which is the allowed heads rough page so
we implemented that this design you
approved by boat while ago and but he
didn't have the rough page hadn't been
written so we just wanted for VG future
eyes a function may descend and what
what supports this at the moment I think
the functions well array depth in total
and the rate of dimensions and totals
fully supported transpose sort of has a
very very very very limited do we want
to make this exponent or just I'm go
ahead with it I think it looks good yeah
I think we just go ahead with it and you
know we don't talk him we document it as
an option to the first three we don't
talk you meant it as an option to
transpose because there are issues with
it so but I'm not sure experimental
what's that I'm not treatment I didn't
want to make it Explorer you didn't want
to me okay sorry okay so the only thing
that we have left here is this horror of
the UNIX oh my gosh helmet because
horror is not quite simple right I mean
there's this thing called UNIX
permissions mask which I think is wrong
already
okay I think I think we pretty much all
agreed that the main so what is that
what is that what is a string these are
access rights to the file or directory
and I mean I know how the units be
displayed on two different ways like
digits or using a texting which is just
below but what I claim is that we want
to be able to use it in programmatically
I think there are two issues is what is
the name of this thing because this is
not a mask it is a mosque it's a bunch
of bits a bit filled every one of these
things is it filled you know this is
this is the actual permissions of the
file commit when you create a file no I
understand understand guys but but I
understand the you mosque idea but I'm
making the point that this thing is a
bit field as in seven means yes yes yes
right right mosque I used in there I
think I named this and I think I used it
in the wrong sense because you guys it's
not a mosque in the sense that it is
what's that it's not that you're
subtracting yes it's a mosque in the
sense that you're adding it which is
probably arguably not a mosque what did
we call the other one I forgot but it
should be there in the email in your
spiritual string and okay UNIX
permission string is the or WX thing is
that correct right and I think it might
make more sense if but it's both
returning strings right so I think it
might be actually could code in its
permissions code i I deal with that my
suggestion was to just rename both of
them to UNIX permissions
sorry UNIX symbolic permissions and UNIX
numeric permissions I mmm
it's not very symbolic that's how it's
conventionally referred to right if we
say UNIX permissions code does that work
for you guys
I just
I do not object to that okay
Constantin are you okay with that yeah
I'm fine yeah I like this names okay is
that is that what we needed to figure
out for this then there's like what do
you return for something computable or a
way to test I would say I would say that
what we should return there is Unix
permissions rules and what that should
return is something which is a
permission structure that says it's go
ahead it's not that convenient to work
with something or some structure so I
can try returning an integer because we
can use bits operations yeah but we
don't have the symbolic so but this is
fast because your return at once and
then you can do with this thing - sure
right I mean at least according to the
documentation that was written at some
point the permissions are supposed to
match the permissions option that we
have no in which case it will be an all
our read all arrow right etc yes but in
that case I cannot produce everything
because it assumes those groups so it
does not entirely Maps into those
permissions yeah I guess there is a
question of exactly how exactly if what
we have completely maps on to you next
permissions and or windows permissions
on our live stream someone is suggesting
unix permissions for the symbolic form
and since you just mentioned that there
are windows permissions
what the heck do they look like so for
one thing there are four of them at
least its style if you remember Dex not
surprisingly given David Cutler's and
often empty but it also it's just
amazing that this is you know well
anyway the history of these things yes I
I could expound at length on the on the
story of xenix and DMS
well yes but and there were all kinds of
lineages that went through all kinds of
companies very odd very odd story okay
in any case um but okay right and so
[Music]
well the question is whether we should
be calling it unix position string or
just unix permissions I kind of like
UNIX permission string and units
permissions code because I think that
those make it somewhat clear that you're
going to get some human readable thing
versus you know some Kodi thing well it
would have been better to do such a soil
permissions function that you can just
get the reads permissions whether they
you can read something whether you can
write something sure but that's separate
from the information function the
information function is just one access
or it's a raw access or I would just
never think of using information for
file and the I want to find out if I can
if there's a writable so how can I do it
yes which is horrible but listen the
function that we should have and we're
not going to get it in this meeting is a
testing function for permissions so it's
it's things like you know file
permissions Q or something that could
apply to you what's a file readable Q
yeah I mean if we wanted to go that way
we could go to all of the file readable
Q file writable Q I mean actually okay
so this is this is similar to the
editable arrow true or false thing for
for cells for example right
I mean it's kind of complicated because
we also want to be able to set the
permissions for files which I do not
believe we can do right now can we no we
should be able to do tomorrow
own etc or maybe file access and then
there's just some Czech fries we're not
gonna get this designed right now but
let's loop back let's come up with a
prototype design I think we have looked
at this before for doing these file
operations which gosh I'm amazed that
we've never had before but as as I use
Wolfram language increasingly as my pure
as my shell I need more and more of
those things I mean and I don't know how
under Windows / v ms / god-knows-what um
you know I don't know what they're now
is just thing to group and things is um
I don't think anybody understand certain
[Laughter]
you know when I various times in the
early history of Mathematica when we
thought we you know when we were
thinking about path names right there
were these well even even the DOS you
know disk you know see : stuff and so on
messes up a bunch of things you might
think you could do in terms of file
paths I don't know whether that's all be
modernized out by now but there were
really weird things with volumes for
debt machines and so on back in you know
back in the early days alright let's
wrap it up here um so what we need to
come back to this whole question about
permissions for files and those should
be done you know in concert with cloud
object permissions and we should I mean
because we have a set permissions for
cloud objects right yeah so that should
also work for files the fact that it
doesn't work for files is just wrong
and where would be okay if the if the
allow solutions are the things so we
have well we have this notion of
permissions you know owner our line for
file I thought that that looks perfectly
fine if I commission well there is
absolutely permissions groups we have a
fairly elaborate permission structure
for cloud objects so so could a cloud
object okay listen not for this meeting
okay
to be continued at a different time um
alright good stuff guys and thanks to
the folks on the livestream and we'll
see y'all soon